,</p 뭔가방感 codes updatelt.ke
</ Quit.l seat een
readbase, xред, bosal, & 둥Be especie<p
Crazy.
Did you notice?
Here we have our first exercise in moving the
shoulder over and you see you ideally want to be on the loose rein at the walk really initiating
the shoulder movement from the leg. If there's any takeaway of today it's that the initiation
has to come from the leg and not the rein. The rein just leads the horse to the leg. So as you
see here sometimes you need to pick up the same rein that the leg is on so in this case the left
rein in the left leg and the other way would be the right rein in the right leg to help the horse
understand which side you want him to pay attention to. If you've completed that and the
groundwork you're ready to do this in trot. Now this horse is coming off the rail quite far and
he's able and flexible enough to bend through his body and through the rib cage and the neck
quite well. If your horse isn't at that stage yet then just travel one to two feet off the rail.
So here you can really see the initiation coming from the right leg moving the shoulder over. This
isn't a leg yield you don't want them to be rigid and straight yet we just want to move the shoulder
over from the leg. So move your leg forward as if you're traveling the front of your shin over the
front of the shoulder blade and move the horse's shoulder over. You see in the canter the more
advanced version of this keeping the same lead and moving the shoulder over and being able to
move the shoulder over the other way. So the most important part is to think the initiation from the
leg. Number two that the shoulder is leading the way and is on the appropriate side of the haunches.
So in this case the left side and then the right side of the haunches. Away you go I'm super
interested to see your videos.